[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we sit
through philosophy to find practical
advice that you can use in your everyday
life hi I'm Dan Hayes I'm joined by my
co-host Dr Greg Sadler today we're going
to talk about Venture Brothers neoism
Conflict and hope and so this is a
little bit of a departure but this is
something we've been wanting to do for
quite a while because both Dan and I
geek out over this really wonderful
animated show and uh we've got a lot of
cool stuff lined up for you um this is
going to be a bit different than most of
the episodes since we're focusing on a
cartoon which I don't think we've ever
done before other than little
discussions perhaps yeah no and you know
we are we are going to try to draw some
practical lessons for our everyday life
from these um Larger than Life figures
and narratives and we're going to bring
in some philosophical themes we
mentioned neoism already so we'll have
to explain what that is um and I do have
to warn you there's going to be spoilers
and all the spoilers yeah I mean if
somebody wants to complain about that
the show has been out for a very long
time so I think it's fair game right
yeah the last season was what two years
ago at least maybe more yeah yeah
movie's been out for months I think I
watched it during Co does that sound
right uh maybe something like that it's
it's been a while it's been a while that
we can't even remember how far a wild is
exactly yeah yeah and it's a show that
took a long time to drip and drab out
too you know yeah you get one season
every like two years and in part because
like it was really run by this like Twan
crew like you know obviously it there's
animators and whatnot but like only two
people were writing it and and the the
scripts were probably the things that
you know if you watch the show you know
that like all the animation was fine
it's really entertaining but the the
scripts are the soulle of that show
yeah and I would say it's got some
really great Voice work too you know lot
lots of interesting talent that gets
brought in so we should you know for
anybody who's wondering what are these
guys talking about now we came here for
philosophy we should probably explain
what's the Venture Brothers so you want
to tackle that or um it is a show OB
sensivity about a family The Venture
family but and they are you know kind of
this like mash up between The Hardy Boys
and the um Johnny quests of the world
you know they go on adventures there's
super science there's uh you know big
Burly uh bodyguard that's going to
protect them but this is is it's really
kind of like a jumping off point into
this kind of like this world that is um
like people cosplaying as superheroes
and villains but with very very
meticulous rules and what it it be like
if like regular people had um like
superpowers and but also were like kind
of both
narcissists um as well as kind of bad at
what they do sometime a lot of the times
that's true it's not like the boys where
like they're they're narcissists and
they're like evil and and everything
[__] it's like it's
fun yeah and and so this is a show that
ran for a very very long time and it
produced a good amount of you could say
footage right so there's 81 episodes
there's seven seasons and then there
were a couple uh special episodes that
were an hour long and um they include
the pilot in that too yeah and then the
movie I mean the movie is not like over
long too I think it's about 90 minutes
yeah just under yeah and um you know
Adult Swim canceled it after the seventh
season it was supposed to have an eighth
season and so the movie is sort of a
consolation prize I guess and trying to
wrap everything up and I I think they
succeeded I mean what do you think
having having watched it absolutely and
like I I see that the bones there like
you know the whole um uh Arch subplot I
think could have easily taken up a
number of episodes I think there's a lot
of aspects of that you know kind of like
modern technology taking over this like
kind of like
uh clandestine and very bureaucratic
paper pushy um kind of organizations
that they run but this is kind of giving
far
field yeah so I we should say what we
mean by that term Arch because it plays
a huge role in The Venture Brothers so
Dan already mentioned that things are
rather organized even bureaucratic in
how and it's kind of funny too so we
would say heroes and villains but the
main villain organization The Guild of
calamitous intent doesn't like that
language they prefer protagonist and
antagonist and there's like I remember
actually they they get out the manual at
at one time maybe in season one and it's
pretty thick and there's like all these
rules about how you're allowed to be the
um now arching is being the arch villain
arch nemesis Archen enemy that's that's
what it stands for right so you you get
to be you have to go through like this
process and then you're assigned
somebody who's close to you in power and
Prestige for you to be the Archen enemy
too and that's like a sign as a hero or
protagonist that you've actually made it
you've got somebody to Arch you but they
could be at the lowest possible level I
mean we get we get to see what level one
Arch and arches brick frog yeah or or uh
what was his name uh St Cloud um oh yes
do you remember his first name uh
his only Power is he's got lots of money
yeah right it's like I buy things it's
like oh you wanted that well I bought it
yeah he um he goes as the cloud and his
his you know weapons are like smoke
and some sort of zapper gun or something
like that very L yeah yeah um and then
like you know another one is is is Brick
porog whose powers are
wielding a brick and yelling his name
brick frog yeah so you know as you as
you mentioned a little bit earlier um it
is a series that gets to show us pretty
pretty weak pathetic characters as well
as like super heroic or super scary
characters um and you know as you
mentioned there's like this entire vast
narrative universe that spills out of
this with all these cool characters who
wind up being developed it's not I guess
you could say it's not like shows where
you've got like the team you know think
about like the Super Friends um you know
you got Superman Wonder Woman Aquaman
who always gets kind of you know pushed
off to the side Batman and Robin and who
am I leaving out um every once in a
while there's an appearance by like
Green Lantern or The Flash and and you
know the other characters don't really
matter other than you know some villains
and the villains are just kind of boring
it reminds me a lot of like um what the
Game of Thrones or the song of Ice you
know you've got you've got your your a
sens of protagonist like the Stark
family whatnot but then you you are for
a large periods of time spending time
with these other characters that are
main characters in of themselves to
their own stories and it's not this like
good guys and you're only in their first
person VI but you're you're constantly
shifting perspectives and um you know
there's here's now an episode about uh
the Monarch and you know it might not
even been being him like doing his
arching thing against Venture he might
be doing his other thing with like um
one of his other story lines with like
uh KO and the um um yeah where green
Moro yeah the green blue morpho so blue
morpho blue modeled after Green Hornet
that's right yeah with with KO and toe
Gary this place yeah yeah or I mean the
Rivalry between him and Phantom limb you
know oh yeah which ends up getting him
arrested uh tried and and put in prison
by the end of the first season and then
there's a whole like him breaking out
and and regaining his like mantle as
Monarch and whatnot yeah I mean that was
one of the really great things about the
show
is you you could say that the Venture
Brothers remain front and center but
there's so many other interesting
developed characters some of whom are
villains some of whom are heroes and
some just kind of like in
between um like you know conjectural
Technologies Pete white Pete white and
Billy B Billy quiz boy yeah so and and
they we find out about all their
backstories and their rivalries and and
it's and it's fed to us in the right way
it's not like they're like and now we
will do a show on you know this thing we
get we get bits and pieces of it and you
kind of have to put it all
together and they've got a really
interesting way of doing their narrative
um like you always get to the end of the
episode right before the credits always
feels really unfinished like there
there's something that happened in the
episode it's like in most stories they
would wrap up this portion of this story
with a nice little bow and youd feel
nice and good but they're like ah that
is secondary to the characters the
characters are the most important here
though the plot lines like you know that
there Brock's going to beat up the guy
or whatever anything that like should be
just expected
happens always watch after the credits
because there's always an extra scene
sometimes it will help to wrap up things
and sometimes it's it's just another
good joke and uh never never miss out on
that I like what you said about it's
really about the characters and so
coming back to this theme of neoism if
we're worried about like the really big
picture then it's it's whether we're
talking about the Venture Brothers we're
talking about other things sometimes we
can fall into a kind of nealis frame of
mind where we're like so neoism you know
means a number of different things but
one thing you can say there's ultimately
no meaning in life we can have local
meaning but we can't have like we can't
have the real nice wrap everything up
together kind of meaning and you know
you look at the story lines of these
people so every organization is a
failure um nobody really gets what they
want for more than a certain amount of
time I mean the Monarch gets uh you know
uh whatever we want to call her Dr
Girlfriend misses the Monarch you know
but there's always wrinkles in it and um
Rusty never gets to meet his his father
and sort of like you know settle scores
with him in any useful way I mean he
does find his father stuck in uh the
computer Matrix at a certain point right
then there's that alien who pretends to
be his father and he gets all mad yeah
he gets all mad at at him um and but you
know when we think about it in terms of
the characters that's where we get a
kind of hope so you can't have super big
picture Grand narrative meaning anymore
because that always collapses but you
can have
local um this is good enough you know
we'll we'll live with this kind of
meaning you could say which might you
know I mean if there's a grand message
maybe that's that that's all you get
yeah it's you know it really comes back
to the the characters and the
relationships between them and if you
especially as as you we get to the end
of the SE series it really does focus on
those families and the the creations of
them uh even though most of them are
like these mixed families these Blended
families or these chosen and families um
yeah and and if there's any meaning to
be derived from the Venture Brothers
universe is it's that's the thing that
you can you know base your meaning
around that be your Locus you know part
of what happens too is as the
characters let's say age or mature
they're able
to at least with some of them get over
their hatred their rivalry their
conflicts with each other and be like H
still don't like you but um you know I
don't have to be motivated completely by
destroying you anymore the the exception
being the monarch of course but with him
it's
um there's a in in the end of the movie
Let me see what you think about this
okay it's a it's a existential
reaffirmation of his hatred which now
turns out to be something not just
psychologic but even genetic CU he's got
that baboon DNA built into his system
and baboons are pretty nasty creatures
you know well as well as he's got you
know Jonas in there and he's kind of a
oh yeah just terrible person yeah I mean
just a dick bag that's true yeah yeah um
and he he reaffirms that but it's
something that he's done at other points
like there's actually this great scene I
don't remember if this is in the first
season where the Monarch who's you know
Dr venture's
self-proclaimed Arch Enemy uh Dr Venture
doesn't take him that seriously he he
steals with um Sheila his his girl doct
girlfriend into Dr Ventures lab and he's
like let's let's wreck stuff and all
that and then he's looking around he's
like ah this is pathetic you know he's
not really a super scientist at all this
is really sad and then you know she
she's like saying should we just go home
honey and then somebody comes in the lab
and I don't remember who it is and then
the Monarch gets out his his little
shooting gun from on on his wrist and he
shoots the person full of darts and now
he's like reinvigorated he's ready to
fight you know that's like the whole
meaning of his existence and it it
really is and it's really in like this
um
grand um conflict with like the guild
because the guild is is constantly
holding him back and so like the we
should say the guild are because I
people who haven't watched this they
talk a little bit but I'll get to so the
Guild of glamist intend is a an
organization by which there is organized
violence or um arching uh against Mayhem
is another word they use yes organized
Mayhem um and so it's it's a a set of
doctrines set down by was the Friendship
agreement and if it's like the last
season season 7 it's um oh I just wrote
it down here um well goes back a long
ways and and uh one of the Venture Pro
uh progenitors is a member of it until
he leaves right so Dr Ventures Russy
venture's grandfather is was a member of
it and then his father Jonas Venture uh
was the one that's um helped broker the
Friendship Accords which set down The
rules the Giant rule book that you were
talking about earlier right and then in
season 7 they reup the Friendship
Accords back at the the destroyed
Venture Compound that's right yeah and
so the guild is the bad guys although
interestingly there's there's we find
out there's a time period where the
guild sort of like in Star Wars they
believed the Sith were gone um everybody
believed that the guild had finally
vanished and they're instead they're
fighting Sphinx which is sort of like
cobra in GI
Jo and they it's not sort of like it is
everything except for the name well
Cobra was black themed sphin Sphinx is
yellow and and brown
themed but yeah the Sphinx Commander
like he he's got that lispy thing like
like Cobra Commander did you know um so
the episode from season s where they do
this friendship thing is the immort
consequence um and uh he says um you
know uh there's this beautiful little um
line from Dr Venture says um you guys
are children he
realizes why they have to have these
Accords because there's there's these
adults who are playing at you know being
like the the the Mao
uh really amazing like uh spies and army
guys and then you've got the the guys
that playing as as the the villain
nefarious yeah nefarious and and you
have to have some rules in place
otherwise it's just going to be Mayhem
and if you didn't have that you'd have
like all like a level 10 Arch you know
uh going after a level one super
scientist and and you see that with the
Monarch where he's just like offing them
right right at one season it's like you
have to have some sort of of fair play
otherwise this whole thing it just ends
you you Arch and then you you one of you
dies and then none of you can continue
playing the game you know what else we
kind of find out too as they move from
like place to place is there's always
some local organization or order or
something like that when they go to New
York for example I forget the name of it
but there's like it's essentially almost
like a protection racket of of
superheroes um it pretends to be like
the the Justice League that's right yeah
but it's got a guy who's an Archer and
just as useless as Hawkeye yeah oh his
name is the Fallen Archer one of my
favorite puns the entire
show yeah and he shoots little arrows
that have little feet in the end of them
it is is masterful their leader is is a
sort of Captain America type is that
right stars and guarders that's right
yeah and then what was the name of the
Lana yeah she's a Wonder Woman type
except she rides um a chariot pulled by
Swans is it or geese maybe close enough
yeah but she's got the lasso you know
she she's very tough but I mean they're
a local part of the order and then like
Canada has its own um the pp um
the yeah what did they St the Peril
partnership Peril partnership yeah so
there all sorts of other
organizations um for a while some of the
OSI guys take over Sphinx and and use
the old Sphinx stuff to go do whatever
they want to do you know so there's a
lot of different we could say not just
moving Parts but moving relationships
and organizations in the whole thing
right and uh during this the second
friendship uh conference um that we were
just talking about here it it was I had
the strong feeling of um like a uh
ecumenical meeting within the Catholic
church or like post World War I what is
the um Versa treaty them sitting down in
a room and we're just like we are going
to determine like what is what is Canon
and not we're going to determine like
what the rules are and where the
boundaries are and you all have to like
do that it just it had this great
parallel of um we look at these guys
these uh heroes are and and or these
protagonists and antagonists and the
whole like scheme that they're making
they they are creating this from Whole
cloth and once again this is kind of
like that whole um you know nihilism but
now you have to build it from yourself
because it's not out there you have to
build it for yourself yeah yeah um so
kind of a making this existential leap
here um uh but
that a lot of the things that we build
in our own
world could be seen as just as silly you
know think of like people buying soccer
clubs and the like uh or any sort of
like sports teams and like okay well I
got this and and I'm going to like try
to position myself here and we're going
to go and like make the rules for how
everyone has to engage and like oh you
know this guy's Too Tall or like they
can't do like the sky hook anymore
because you know otherwise like Wilt
Chamberlain totally dominates everyone
like it's it's these these fictions that
people get into little room that you
mention Sports because I've seen you
know how like people wear their team's
jerseys and stuff like that I've seen
that described as geek
cosplay you know
absolutely absolutely not geek jock
cosplay Jo cosplay yeah the Geeks you
know dress up in their DND D stuff or as
superheroes or pick whatever else you
want and that is no more silly than as I
often do you know putting on a packer
Jersey
right so and and if you go outside of
the area of like you know uh sports or
anything like this is also like you can
make parallels to how we run governments
it's like you know well or or
corporations like these are fictions
that we have created there are human
constructions and a lot of the things
that we do especially in like protocol
from an outside Observer would seem to
be Petty and and and outside of any
reason to actually exist yeah it's I
mean this is a total side note but I'm
often just struck by the you know you
see these people who have like billions
and billions of dollars and own gigantic
corporations and the stupid decisions
that they make and you're like you got
so much money and you couldn't hire
somebody to like help you make a good
decision in terms of like you know their
public declarations or PR or you know uh
the products that they're bringing out
you're like couldn't you like just hire
a couple people to do some of the
thinking for you and and you're like I
guess they can't really be smarter than
any of the rest of us you know just in
certain ways you know yeah like I I've
I've met quite a few billionaires right
now in my life and yeah they're nothing
special as far as I've been able to
ascertain like they made some really
lucky bets and they had the resources um
but you know most of them are just
run-of-the-mill they're yeah maybe know
a little bit above average and intellect
but like if you look at the the
breakdown of people who are the richest
it's not the smartest um you got to be
even the people that you would think
would be the smartest so in Academia
right we've got this distinction between
like the elite
universities Harvard MIT stuff like that
and then everybody else right I've met a
lot of people from these Elite
universities what students professors
people who've graduated from them
they're not any smarter than the rest of
us they're just better connected and
they they have a lot of you know assets
that we don't we don't have and they
they knew to go to those places because
you know maybe they had parents that
went there or something like that and
it's it's kind of refreshing to see I
think for coming back to the nalism
thing I think that some people would
find that dismaying though they would be
like I really need there to be people
who really do know what the hell they're
doing and think that the world is
well-managed by these gigantic
corporations run by you know people with
lots of power and Prestige and pedigree
U otherwise there's something wrong with
the world you know but the the way it
works is you know we're all just kind of
muddling through yeah there's enough
people that are good enough exactly yeah
well you don't have to have like
Geniuses everywhere and also I don't
like the idea of labeling people
Geniuses yeah um but uh you have to have
enough people there that do it well
enough have enough like back log of
people that are experience that can help
bring the new people up to Snuff and
have enough like institutional knowledge
with policies that make sure you don't
make the dumb move like you know more
than half the game is just not making
the wrong move not that you have to make
Right Moves just don't do something
that's gonna set you back yeah true and
and a lot of people can't resist making
the wrong move you know it's part of
what we call hubis right yeah but you
know we should we should move on to to
something
um so we'll come back to who the Venture
Brothers actually are but one of the
things we wanted to talk about our
favorite characters because we got you
know I put out a call on social media
what what would you like us to talk
about and so people said yeah who are
your who's your favorite character and I
thought I was like oh man that's tough I
don't have a single favorite character
and even coming up with like my top
three I'm finding rather difficult but I
thought three might be more
manageable so do you want to go first
with who you're or do you want to go
back and forth back and forth okay well
who so who's your favorite
like first one on my list here okay yeah
yeah Dr orus oh interesting this um he's
he's uh trying to be good dad he's want
he wants to get an arch he's over the
toop he's a doctor strange like
character but uh he lives in the the the
Mother-in-law suite at the Venture
Compound and uh because he's divorced
because somebody seduced his wife and
his wife ran off with him um so he's
kind of you know dealing with that as
well but I think you're right he is a
genuinely good guy like way better than
Dr Venture oh yeah absolutely you know
we we'll stop at any moment to help boys
whenever they need um just and he's he's
over the top in just the way that I like
people to be over the
top
so the person that I'm GNA pick first is
a villain and how can you not like him
the mighty Monarch AKA blue Moro you
know AKA
Malcolm I mean he's he's I mean some
people have actually argued that he is
the main character that do that Dr
Venture is not the main character that
if anybody deserves to be called it it's
it's the Monarch I think he's he's
actually got the most lines you know it
is called The Venture Brothers and you
know once again we're going to hit that
spoiler Dr Venture and Malcolm the
Monarch his arch enemy is his almost
exact clone yeah you know they're
they're they're blood relatives they are
literal Brothers um there there's
another also uh JJ
but um oh there was there was that scene
where uh Rusty Venture Dr Venture is
dressed up in the blue Moro costume that
um the Monarch has been wearing and he's
got just the right beard and because
he's got the Hat on you can't tell that
he's balding uh and it's exact his own
wife takes him as being um that guy
you're
right um and so like you it's starts off
and you think the story The Venture
Brothers the titular Venture Brothers
are Hank and Dean and really it's it's
at least those two
yeah um you want to talk about that or
should we should we continue on with our
three let's go on we can yeah we'll come
back to that so who's who's your number
two then uh shie he oh interesting he he
just uh you can't say who he is because
I think people is part of the OSI he is
on oh I don't know if he's more modeled
on a g Joe Navy guy or so yeah it's like
that plus across with the the um uh
Village People uh yeah right the Village
People sailor he's he's buff he's
absolutely in charge and he's flaming
gay yeah um and he he loves it and and
um he absolutely owns it and he uh just
is a great friend he's incredible
combatant and just every
every single line is just dripping with
gold yeah I I think he he he really is a
a great
character um I mean number the number
two one for me Brock Samson I mean how
again how can you not have him in there
he's you know at the very start he was
my absolutely favorite character um and
he does have you know a lot of growth
arcs and stuff like that he's he's
essentially brute they call him the uh
Swedish killing machine right cuz he's
this hulking guy voiced by Patrick War
Burton um he just like beats the crap
out of everybody he won't use a gun
because he much prefers to use his hands
or a knife you know he's just so over
the top you know absolutely but he I
mean he goes through some tough times oh
absolutely um you know uh love and loss
and uh you know wounds and heavy Hunter
uh helper embedded in his chest for a
while all right I forgot about that yeah
yeah so so who is who's your third
choice
Dr Henry Killinger oh wow you you had
some really like I wouldn't have
predicted these at all these are deep
Cuts he he's a really cool character so
he he's modeled on Henry Kissinger the
um but he's not
evil no he is evil but he is lawful evil
okay um and he really shows out like you
know he at one point in times he he
tries to tempt um Dr Venture into being
a villain that's an absolutely amazing
episode oh right um and then he also
like there's um these other villains the
accountants who are are there's always
this like this push and pull between
like um we talked about the The Guild
being this like bureaucracy that kind of
holds the the whole
artifice together so that it doesn't
like devolve into chaos and they wanted
to destroy that and so Henry Killinger
comes out and like Darth Vaders them um
like literally they have a big like
lightsaber battle it's and he's like
he's
evil um very affable he's like Mary
Poppins um he flies in with a
umbrella and he has a a murder mystery
bag that's a little doctor's bag um
just a lovely out there character like
Kissinger I have no love for but I do
have love for Killinger
yeah I would say the one the other
person who I I really really like is um
one of the few female characters that
we've talked about starts out as Dr
Girlfriend turns out she's got a
backstory as Queen atheria and um what
was it that when she had the mopets uh
lady opair and then then she becomes
doct girlfriend and then eventually
becomes Dr Mrs the
Monarch she she is um you know she
becomes part of the new Council of 13
for the guild after this big
bloodletting that goes on and she's a
badass and she is um she's the one
person the Monarch is actually afraid of
although he loves her too right and um
she's she's the force of order within
the guild and she's got this Loose
Cannon husband who is going off and
doing stuff he's not supposed to be
doing while she's trying to like
reorganize this entire world of of or of
you know antagonism and and evil and um
she's they're they're opposites in lots
of ways the Monarch and and Mrs the
Monarch yeah in part of like he is that
that pure hatred and she loves him for
it but she's also so very much disorder
and like in bureaucracy incarnate and
there it's there's that that push and
pole between them on like they they
absolutely love each other they are
totally devoted like there's that's a
great love story yeah I mean and and she
will do anything for him but she's also
often quite pissed off at
him there's there's actually a great
episode before they get get married
where I think they're engaged at the
time and the monarchs henchmen who are
just a bunch of screw-ups managed to
capture not only the boys but also Brock
Samson and maybe uh also Dr Venture and
they've got him in holding cells and she
uh she comes in and she's like I can't
believe that you're arching him that
you're doing this and he's like oh no no
no the boys just wanted to see the
inside of the cell you know they're
actually here for the party you know and
then he's like you guys got to play
along with this and and they're all like
yeah yeah okay whatever you know
so yeah so should we talk about who the
The Venture Brothers actually are really
quick I have a a a couple of honorable
mentions not so much that I love their
characters but I'm a sucker for puns and
I couldn't go out without saying um wide
whale yeah who is a whale who wears
corduroy um Archer he's an Archer that
has little Fallen foot arches um Phantom
limb um he's a villain that has no limbs
or at least in no visible limbs um
copycat he's a uh a 1920s like James
Dean cat type guy um but uh he can copy
himself he multiplies himself um Think
Tank he's a a professor right has a
giant head and rides around a little
tank um and and haranga Tang who man
half angry
rang yeah those I mean they do they have
got a ton of great puns and I we should
say one other character who if we're
gonna do honorable mentions
like maybe crowd favorites Gary oh Gary
who's henchman 21 also Sphinx Commander
for a while uh what else he he is uh um
Kano along with the blue Monarch so he
wears a lot of masks and he has like
this crazy crazy Arc as well you know he
starts off I think he he starts off you
got like kidnapped by them at 15 like I
was rewatching the first season and like
and then he turns into um a uh a badass
as um as capable is Brock by the end
that's that's another thing I mean
there's this scene where um he's at the
Venture The Venture Compound is having a
yard sale of like technology and he
finds a lightsaber and he's a Star Wars
nerd right and so he like he he thinks
he has a real lightsaber and he goes up
to Brock Samson and he like you know
tries to cut him with it and it doesn't
work because it's not a real lightsaber
and then Brock Samson basically like
says boo to him and he run he has takes
off right um but there is that scene
where he goes toe-to-toe with Brock
Samson and neither of them win right so
and and it's it is totally like earned
like you see his development from kind
of pudgy totally useless atten to more
and more competent to the point where
you know you can go Toe to Toe he
probably is one of the people who has
the biggest Arc like like you're saying
it is something that he does on the way
there's no like and then he got bit by a
radioactive spider it's he does all the
work required for it and at the very end
of season 7 he and the Monarch go
through this crazy initiation thing and
they both emerge Masonic yeah they both
emerge as level 10 villains and he's no
longer a henchman he's he's equal to the
Monarch which is kind of cool yeah uh so
what was the next oh well we're gonna
we're gonna go back to who the actual
Venture Brothers are you mentioned so
Hank and Dean at the start you're like
okay this is the Venture Brothers right
because they're always doing go team
Venture holding their fingers out and it
turns out that they're actually clones
that you know who knows how many of them
have died over the the years and there's
even a misshapen clone of Dean
around um and then we find out you know
that Thaddius venture has this twin that
he absorbed in the
womb uh Jonas jenter Jonas Venture Jr
who escapes and he at first they think
he's a tumor yeah and realized
that Rusty had ate him in utero
yeah and he's and he's a good guy you
know uh he is everything that you would
hoped that his father was like the the
veneer that his father was you know
Jonas Venture yeah who's a terrible
terrible father um
and yeah and although uh one of the
worst things I thought he did was was
Ron out well not rcon it was at the very
end like they say that um he never
actually
um had an affair with the blue moros
wife right um and and I thought he did
like it's like that was totally I
thought it was his character but no he
was actually a good friend to him and he
and he they couldn't conceive and they
gave him uh malcol yeah so uh then we
get another wrinkle we have dermit and
at first uh we're led to believe that
dermit is actually Brock Samson's
illegitimate kid cuz he's kind of beefy
kind of
dumb but turns out he's Rusty's kid too
so now there's three Venture Brothers at
least in the let's call it third
generation right um and there's three in
the first or the second the second we
got we got Jonas right right yeah yeah
we got two sets of three Al so now who's
the third and so you got um JJ Dr
Venture and Malcolm or find out that the
Monarch is also a clone um that he's got
some baboon DNA to how do they put it to
like spice him up or something to give
him some to give him hair
oh
okay 2% baboon DNA keep the hair so I
guess you could say we have six Venture
Brothers total right at least yeah yeah
once again you have the other clones and
there's that one that's misshape and
it's still around and um I think he dies
though doesn't he oh okay yeah yeah but
I mean so so does Jonas so right um but
we got lots of Brothers but like the
main one the main the main ones you
think are just you know two and then you
figure out there's this another set of
two and now it's actually three and
three that are the main characters
around so I mean I like that
ambiguity um we don't know who who
exactly counts as a venture brother um
part of it is as you pointed out this
incredibly important role the theme of
family um who who counts as family who
doesn't you know because they it seems
to be that um Rusty is May and Malcolm
might be direct clones of uh Jonas their
father um and that Dean seems to be a
direct clone of
Rusty um but Hank doesn't seem to be
not because
um Hank is the he got I believe it's
implied that they got uh eggs from um oh
what was the the villain in the the
movie there um oh invisible lady um yeah
uh Mrs she becomes Mrs ma majer right
she's married to force majer um but no
her her daughter right uh yeah I
shouldn't know this but I mean maybe he
takes more after his mom than he does
that side um but you're right yeah I
mean a blonde blonde kid like that and
then dermit doesn't look anything like
them either you know well I think dermit
was like the trist
yeah oh and and Hank has sex with that
same oh God that's where he loses his
virginity which then he is uh forced to
forget about you know yeah um failure
Okay so but quickly so failure like we
talked about the show and how it is a
little bit like a big theme is failure
but they do fail a lot but yeah failure
is has two major uses within the show
one is it's hilarious like seeing people
fail in really embarrassing ways is like
inherently funny yeah that's true oh
it's all like shod and frer right
especially because like like Rusty Dr
is kind of a bad person so it's like you
know look at it's always something in
Philadelphia or even like Seinfeld it's
like it feels good to kind of laugh at
these people that are kind of bad people
right um and but also failure is a path
for for growth and you see this that
often times
Rusty and the team will fail into what
seems to be a a hole that they can't get
out of which then turns into something
that will actually be of great use and
actually beneficial well and and not
just them I mean the Monarch does that
too winding up in prison right um
figuring out how to get himself out of
that uh the Cocoon gets destroyed he's
got to like rebuild from scratch he's
got to start over in his parents old
house in uh some crappy part of New
Jersey I want to say yeah some some
slummy area you know um and and yet he
he keeps on you know he runs out through
his trust fund right so now he's got to
figure out where he's going to get money
from um runs out of eyebrow wax at a
certain point the poofy eyebrows yeah so
and um I mean who else is like learning
from their failures in this um I mean
hunter
gathers right based on Hunter Thompson
yeah who he's a really interesting
character I mean he's the one who Grooms
Brock for the
OSI he and Brock are the only ones who
sort of like xfiles kind of stuff they
they're the only ones who believe the
guild is still out there um and uh
eventually they both become important
operatives but hunter gathers goes
undercover has a sex change to do so
which he really wants you know uh
joining was the black hearts um that
right tail started uh M
um
uh a mercenary group of women you know
um so yeah there's there's a lot of
interesting learning from
failure now we we took some excerpts
because this has been so well documented
from what um the the writers actually
had to say and um do hammer and Jackson
Public yeah and so early on they were
saying yeah failure is what the Venture
Brothers is all about beautiful Sublime
failure um you know the show is actually
all about failure even in the design
everything's supposed to be kind of the
death of the Space Age dream world but
then they changed their minds about it a
bit later because I I guess it got kind
of done to death you know I suppose you
go to enough conventions and people are
like oh man the shows about failure
you're probably going to push back on it
right there's only so much
deconstruction and and a superhero they
can do by making them fail to the point
where like well now what do you do you
have to like you've deconstructed to the
ground so you have to build something
new yeah so what comes after failure
then for for gross rebuild you know like
you know we've been talking about a
little bit like you know
um the ventures are are constantly on
the brink of of bankruptcy and they
always find something at the end to like
you know bail them out um even when they
finally like lose everything um they
like uh JJ dies and Beque them all the
stuff and so you know it was like oh
that saved them um and and actually like
they actually produce like you know
really good things like you know um in
in in the later Seasons we have Dr
Venture who's been you know riding on
The Laurels of his father hasn't made
anything new actually makes a couple of
really incredible things like the
teleporter um and then and then in the
very end um they're uh they make these
like um uh I or airpod like devices um
they're they're way over engineered
they're not going to actually probably
sell especially for the price that they
want that they need to to You Know cover
the cost of making them but they figure
out that they've actually made a
anti-gravity drive and that's going to
be actually incredibly useful what were
those called do you remember off hand it
was like a rusty something right or Oh
no you're right it was modeled after a
helper yeah and then they have oh
something helper or help is something
yeah it looks it looks sort of like an
Alexa uh except it's helper's head um
and helper is a robot helper yeah yeah I
and helper's a funny robot too I mean he
gets J super super jealous of other
robots to to a murderous level yeah
right pushes one them off the Venture
Compound yeah but coming back to this
failure thing so um public said uh I
think you and I are both sick of every
interview mentioning it's a show about
failure I don't think we made a
conscious effort to fight that or
anything but every year we push what we
do as a writer at WR as writers a bit
more um an area we hadn't gone into very
much was positivity our victories are
all still satiric but there's definitely
places is where we said I want to see
these guys do something I don't want to
just have everything fall on its face
all the time and you know if you think
about that it's sort of like a failure
and then getting past failure on a meta
level this like oh it's all about
failure and now we're pigeon hold as the
show that's about failure you know
that's a failing right and so they had
to figure out a way to get past that
which I think is kind of a cool
idea definitely like when you're young
like your comedy is is all like a lot of
young comedy is sarcasm are like taking
the thing like fart jokes yeah make make
it gross make it like edgy or something
it's like oh yeah that's funny right but
after a while you've got to like you got
to do something otherwise like your
sarcasm gets old yeah kind of um what is
that what is the the French New Wave in
cinema um because there was a whole
bunch of these critics and they're just
all they were doing was criticizing um
the films and they're like okay well if
you think you're so good then make your
own you did yeah and they made some
amazing stuff so I like you know as long
as you don't constantly stay in the
criticism and you actually eventually
build something I think that's that's a
great uh Arc to go
on yeah you know um another animated
show that I think you could say has done
that a bit but not maybe to the extent
of the Venture Brothers is
Archer you you know I do you watch that
one at all or um I stopped I don't know
when they like were into after a while
yeah
yeah but yeah I can see like you know
eventually they actually became at least
sort of competent in their job like yeah
they were always just like failing yeah
and and failing uh hugely you could say
well we should talk about some of the
other key themes which one do you want
to talk about next um I there was the
family thing I don't yeah I think we
should do family family is really we
don't want to put that to last because
we're getting close to the end of the
hour yeah um well let's do masculinity a
bit because I think there's some really
interesting things and we hit family the
on um so we've got this uh you know a
whole bunch of different uh types of
masculinity here and um we have like our
kind of uh what I guess toxic
masculinity or this like very Macho
masculinity that we could talk about and
Brock really um emphasizes this and we
have um Dr Venture who is this
incredibly like emasculated guy he's
emasculated from his his only appearance
he's very like weak and bald and like um
relatively yeah speed suit um but he's
also got this constant inferiority Pro
uh complex from his not feeling like he
ever can live up to his father either in
prowess with um you know women or
science or money or anything um and then
you have like the boys are these like
you know Hardy Boys at least in the
early Seasons they haven't like
developed into H like their full
characters yeah and you know somebody
else who I would say exemplifies that
that toxic masculinity bit in an old
school sense Phantom limb oh oh yeah
soul controlling
very yeah and he's um he does take well
to rivalry you know he sees the Monarch
as his rival and needs to eliminate him
you know right which is very outside of
like the the whole idea of the guild is
to like the guild oh well I mean you
know Phantom limb tries to carry out a
coup and take over the guild and become
the new Sovereign right so this is like
on you're familiar with finite finite in
infinite games which is a book about
Game Theory um and a finite game is one
where one has to lose and for the other
one to win um where an infinite game is
a game which the the goal of the game is
to keep on playing and so like you know
politics in in part is to keep on
winning uh to keep on playing because if
you like just like destroy them then
you're you're actually going to hurt
yourself especially like in politics if
you're like destroying them then you're
you're you're hollowing out yourself or
your the the whole of your your country
or whatever plac is
um and and he very much is like a finite
games thing whereas you know Dr
girlfriend is uh and the other people
that trying to keep the bureaucracy is
hey we we keep on wanting to do this
forever and ever um if we like you go
too hard they're gonna like Nuke us
that's right yeah so you know we should
talk about some of the female characters
and you know because you could say oh
it's a very male
Centric um
narrative there's many more male
characters than there are female
characters um there's a risk that the
female characters could just be
props um I don't think that's actually
the case I mean do girlfriend Sheila
what whatever we want to call her she
becomes one of the the dominant people
within the guild and um and one of the
most well-rounded characters in the
entire Series yeah I suppose that's
right yeah yeah um yeah then of them
like Sally impossible this is our our
our um invisible girl invisible girl
from the the Fantastic Four analog
except all that turns invisible is her
skin
yeah which creeps other people out right
and so um she she starts off as this
like decoration just kind of like you
know uh The Invisible Woman is kind of
like an afterthought a lot in fantastic
for especially early on and then she
like like gets rid of um uh doctor
impossible um and it's like no like I
I'm
I'm tired of being that second fiddle
that that afterthought it's interesting
too because first she goes after
Thaddius Venture rest Venture and he
just to replace yeah and he is um kind
of a jerk to her you know um he he's he
is narcissistic he treats her kind of
just as a prop and then she winds up
with his his twin um Jonas and he really
loves her and she really loves him and
they're truly happy together you know I
I think that's a great character Arc and
then we've got um you know malov cockes
which is like a like a very James bondy
type villain that's the reason for
her yeah very um UNC name here but um
she's incredibly competent Russian spy
um founder of the black hearts and um
rock is absolutely head over heels for
her um and so she she has her own
objectives and is constantly going at
them is a a con in conflict with the the
ventures or Brock himself um and is
never you know anyone second fiddle um
and it's it's she chooses somebody other
than Brock Brock never gets the girl she
chooses monstroso monstroso yeah yeah I
thought that was a really cool twist
yeah and then there's also this this
idea like we would talk about Brock as
being this kind of
stereotypical um man's man whatnot he's
incredibly buff powerful and he's like
SW well I don't know he's he's rough and
Suave I don't know the what in the way
that like
a um Led Zeppelin fan from the 70s who
he's always playing uh yeah in his car
yes he's a burnout he's he's got icus
tattooed on him as well that's right
yeah um and but he's uh also incredibly
doting like surrogate father for the
boys that
he's essensially being a bodyguard for
them but he's incredibly kind spends
lots of time with them um is is never
like really Curt with them as well as
he's got like he beds lots of women but
the the only the ones that really get
him and and get his heart are um the
women that could potentially very much
hurt him so he's got wariana which is
this Wonder Woman analog on uh moltov as
well as um a another oh a bodyguarding
bodyguard yeah yeah and and these are
the only people that he's like in love
with that's true yeah which is very
opposite of what you might think in that
uh
stereotype yeah and you know with the
wariana thing she's got the this magic
lasso that compels truth and we find out
that she's kinkier than than he is but
he likes it oh
yeah I think he she pegs him that was
yeah yeah we should uh we should wrap up
we're we're nearly at the end of our
time we we we end you we have all these
families are chosen um
and uh we're going to end with this this
quote here from you know the words of
the monarch
Venture and I have been engaged in a dly
game of cat and also cat for
[Music]
years